let's go head to toe set the record
straight
well we've done what we haven't done
once and for all get it out there cuz
people are constantly picking apart how
you so here's the funny part of story
I haven't had a week off in years I've
had a baby and I go back to work
generally like seven days later so when
could you get all this that's what I'm
saying that's what I'm saying okay we'll
go from this so my hair we all know that
I wear a wig so yes this is not real
I've done my lips I have been getting
Botox since I was very very young for
migraines initially and now it's the
obvious reason I've had my boobs done I
fixed my hernia and had like a tummy
tuck at the same you know it's one of
the same I just did all Farrah or the
skin tightening yeah it's a little
uncomfortable I'm like motivated by the
fact of the skin tightening I just did
it on like my knees to see cool right I
just did on my knees but it's not
instant I do like instant gratification
well you remember the the fat melting
you eating the pizza
of course that will that's the gift that
will never die yeah that's definitely
I'm still that person but that's it I've
not done anything else
are you tired of getting asked about
your nose cuz up close yeah I get it I
get the nose because my family does my
mom side has really cute noses why would
I not talk about a nose job actually
I'll show you my septum is completely
out you can see so if I don't know its
job I definitely wouldn't have a second
that's hanging out over here and this is
the other thing like you idiots you
think I'm gonna have a stroke and then
go do something go have plastic surgery
that's really smart
you can't I'm on blood thinners for
another at least another year yeah how
is that impacted you I have a lot more
fear of is it gonna happen again every
time I get a headache I get a little bit
anxious it's not as bad as it was that
day but kinda like PTSD oh it's just
kind of yeah it's just kind of like I
get anxious my hand starts to go to
sleep cuz that's originally how it
started and I'm like ooh you know I I'm
doing better though I feel like I'm kind
of figured yeah I'm kind of getting
better with it figure out the new normal
the new exactly right
you